okay
you use the word coherence now i'm
wondering do you subscribe to a
coherence
theory of truth or a correspondence or a
deflationary
and when you say closer to truth you
have to be
prioritizing one because they conflict
with one another and if what you're
saying is we put the
these intellectuals in the ring and let
them hammer it out well then is it just
social convention which one
emerges as the consensus how are you
defining truth
okay so that's a very broad and
important question
and uh the the first way that i would
approach it is to divide
the ways of thinking about the word
truth
uh there is the the philosophy uh
category the correspondence theory
the various theories of of truth you
need truth makers to make a truth
you know this philosophical
uh approaches to it uh there's ways that
we use
a truth in common usage and then there's
a way that we use
truth in in the common media today and
all of those kind of get
um kind of get mixed up uh together
um and so
that's one way to look at another way to
look at it is you
you can't just define truth
without seeking the context for what
it is so many people will say argument
is truth rel truth is relative if you're
in one set of circumstances one thing
and if you're another set of
circumstances another thing
or if you have a different perspective
on life
death universe god whatever you'll have
different kinds of truths and they're
all
sort of um able to
exist together in some
meta-truth-dimensional
sense the way we look at
truth is that
we deal on closer to truth
with the kinds of questions
that should i can't say absolutely does
but i would feel very strongly that
there is a truth to the questions
we ask on closer to truth than the large
majority in
cosmos consciousness for sure
and potentially on meaning as well and
i'd go out on a limb and say yes so when
all of the
topics that closer to truth deals with
there may be exceptions
that there really is an ultimate truth
that is singular and absolute
and non-relative now do i expect to ever
know that no
do i expect to make progress in
understanding
what those mean i think the answer is
yes because we're able to
ask the kinds of questions and see the
diversity of
smart sophisticated coherent thinking on
these topics
even if they disagree radically on what
that answer is
on what that question is really asking
so i would then take your question about
what is truth
and and limit it to how we deal with
truth on closer to truth
because we deal with the kinds of
questions that
should and i believe do have an ultimate
answer
even if it is not possible even not
possible
in in principle to get to that truth but
the kinds of truths that we seek
do have absolute answers uh and those
are the kinds of questions we want to
ask
that have to do with you know big
big fundamental questions